una escena frecuente en 2020 vuelve a
verse en Toronto en esta ciudad
canadiense muchas personas usan
tapabocas como medida de protección
contra el humo generado por los
incendios forestales
creo en seguir las pautas de salud
pública y si esto es lo que se debe
hacer para protegerse y mantener a otras
personas seguras Estoy totalmente de
acuerdo las autoridades canadienses
indicaron que las llamas han arrasado
con más de 4 millones de hectáreas la
provincia canadiense de Colombia
británica es una de las afectadas
actualmente hay 82 incendios forestales
en toda la provincia y desde el primero
de abril de 2023 382 incendios
forestales han quemado un total de
520.000 hectáreas
como parte de las labores de emergencia
un grupo de bomberos franceses arribó a
Quebec para ayudar a combatir las
conflagraciones pero lejos de las llamas
algunas ciudades de Estados Unidos se
ven afectadas por el humo que está
causando daños en la calidad del aire la
calidad del aire está en un nivel grave
muchas personas no pueden salir y creo
que es sólo un problema de salud general
por otro lado en la ciudad de Nueva York
una de las más golpeadas por la
contaminación activistas realizaron una
manifestación para llamar la atención
sobre el cambio climático